[Música]
la otan celebra una Cumbre
extraordinaria y pone sobre la mesa el
pedido más reciente de Ucrania la
entrega de jets f-16 y f17 para
continuar la guerra contra Rusia de
momento algunos países estudian la
posibilidad mientras que otros como
Estados Unidos han dado un no la
pregunta es si este armamento cambiaría
el ritmo del conflicto y por qué Ucrania
los pide con la misma urgencia con la
que insistió previamente en obtener los
tanques del Leppard vamos a analizar
esto con Antonio barrios Oviedo él es
analista especialista en conflictos
internacionales y en origen y ampliación
de la otan Muchísimas gracias Antonio
por estar en directo a América
muy buenos días Muchas gracias por la
invitación Antonio para comenzar qué
aviones pide específicamente bolodimir
selensky Y por qué son modelos de los
años 70 que aún están activos en Estados
Unidos
sí son son aviones que definitivamente
todavía sirven que campo de batalla
sobre todo porque el tipo de guerra que
Ucrania no es una guerra tampoco tan tan
enorme en todo el territorio y es un
tipo de Aviación que perfectamente le
sirvió a Eugenia para poder enfrentar
esta guerra hay que tener en cuenta de
que toda la guerra el año pasado este el
todo el espacio aéreo ucraniano ha
estado bajo control de la Aviación
militar de Rusia y el darle aviones
actualmente podría darle paso adelante
para que pueda de alguna forma poder
enfrentar O sea que ha estado de alguna
manera partiendo no solamente desde el
aire sino incluso desde el mismo
territorio ruso con misiles distintas
ciudades dentro de Ucrania entonces eso
podría yo no diría que va a cambiar
radicalmente la guerra pero le
permitiría por lo menos a Ucrania poder
enfrentar de manera más efectiva todos
estos ataques que desde el aire pues
Rusia ha estado tratando de hacer sobre
distintas ciudades
entregar aviones desde combate podría
implicar Antonio nuevos peligros como el
hecho de mayores contraataques contra
territorio ruso o que la guerra por
ejemplo se salga de Rusia y Ucrania es
decir nuevos peligros para occidente que
está indirectamente participando en esta
guerra
sí occidente ha sido ha sido muy
incongruente Porque si bien antes
también estaban Opuestos al envío de
tanques y finalmente decidieron enviar
tanques a Ucrania ahora el hecho de que
se esté pidiendo aviones pues
definitivamente podría esto implicar que
Ucrania se atreva a atacar el territorio
ruso Tratando de buscar un
involucramiento de la otan en esta
guerra esto sería definitivamente
catastrófico porque es algo que
evidentemente la gente de la otan no va
a querer occidente en general se opone a
una guerra en la que se tenga que
enfrentar a Rusia y evidentemente pues
si Ucrania se atreve a atacar el
territorio ruso pues Rusia va a tener
que responder de manera más masiva
porque entonces va a haber que
definitivamente es toda una estrategia
de la otan aprovechándose de esta guerra
para ver una situación incluso mucho más
amplia muy peligroso el paso que se
estaría dando dependiendo del tipo de
armamento que le estén dando a Ucrania
bien Y entonces
su discurso coherente de esta semana en
el sentido de pedir que occidente libere
más armamento para Ucrania y que pueda
continuar en la guerra contra Rusia de
Cara a esta llamada contraofensiva de
primavera ahora también ha dicho
stoltenberg que que si bien está en la
mesa la discusión del armamento no es
primaria la discusión sobre la entrega
de jets pero sí se va a hablar de ese
tema qué tan efectivos son estos aviones
contra los misiles y contra los drones
rusos porque hasta ahora en el
suministro de armas extranjeras hacia
Ucrania había primado la defensa
terrestre qué fue lo que cambió
bueno básicamente lo que cambió Bueno
incluso puede cambiar con el envío de
los tanques lo que pasa es que la guerra
puede cambiar porque ya la guerra para
el caso de Ucrania podría tronarse en
una guerra aérea teniendo digamos un
mayor control del espacio aéreo que
hasta el momento ha estado bajo control
de Rusia Entonces el envío de armamento
cada vez más sofisticado No
necesariamente
garantiza un cambio en el curso de la
guerra Eso depende de cómo el ejército
ucraniano hace el uso efectivo del
armamento que está recibiendo para
precisamente pues poder aprovechar las
características del tipo de armamento
que recibe eso no es tan sencillo Porque
si bien se aseguró que el envío de
tanques podía definitivamente cambiar el
curso de la guerra los tanques van a
durar muchos meses en llegar permitir el
entrenamiento de las personas se
requiere todo una logística que requiere
gente especializada que enseña el
ejército ucraniano a manejar
precisamente los tanques Y si llegaran a
enviar aviones también van a requerir un
entrenamiento muy exhaustivo para poder
manejar un tipo de avión al que
ucraniano no está acostumbrado porque
históricamente siempre han tenido
Aviación rusa desde la época soviética Y
ese es el tiempo de Aviación que de
alguna forma les quedó después del
colapso soviético bueno justamente
Noruega anunció hace pocos minutos que
iba a empezar con la entrega de algunos
de estos de estas unidades de los
tanques Leppard ahora quisiera
preguntarle sobre otra retórica
alrededor de la discusión sobre estos
aviones y es la negativa de Joe biden a
entregará los jets de combate sin
embargo durante estos intercambios entre
Estados Unidos y Ucrania Joe biden ha
tenido varias oportunidades en las que
ha dicho no cada vez que goleador hace
pedidos de nuevas tecnologías para la
guerra es tan negativa entonces del
mandatario podría ser temporal porque
también ha advertido que sus recursos no
son infinitos y que no va a continuar la
ayuda al mismo ritmo que viene dándose
Este primer año
Sí sí correcto si en realidad no hay un
cambio sustancial en el campo de batalla
en donde Ucrania demuestre que
definitivamente está logrando avanzar en
la recuperación de los territorios yo
creo que occidente va a tener que ir
mermando el envío de armamento al punto
de que va a tener que privilegiar un
diálogo con Putin la guerra no puede
continuar en El Paso que lleva enviando
armamentos y no hay un cambio sustancial
por otro lado Putin también ha dicho el
reiteradas oportunidades de que Cuanto
más armamentos se envíe de occidente y
Cuanto más avanzado sea Rusia va a tener
incluso que también llevar a cabo
ofensivas cada vez más fuerte lo que
definitivamente Esto va a grabar la
guerra y el hecho de que biden también
esté constantemente diciendo de que no a
tal equipo militar Y luego cambia de
opinión esto lo dejan entre dichos
respecto a la forma en como deberían ser
lo suficientemente congruentes a la hora
de dar una declaración sobre todo cuando
hay una guerra de por medio en Europa
para los jets f-16 y los f-17 están en
poder de Estados Unidos fueron
patentados allí tendría Estados Unidos
que aprobar la transferencia de esta
tecnología desde otros países que puedan
tenerla como los miembros de la Unión
Europea sí sin duda porque es lo mismo
que sucede con los tanques leopard que
Alemania tenía que dar el visto bueno
porque es un tipo de armamento que tiene
está patentado de una forma muy estricta
muchas veces tiene características
tecnológicas que son secretos de estado
y independientemente que el caso de los
aviones f-15 y f-17 ya sean aviones que
han funcionado en muchas guerras el
hecho de Estados Unidos mantener la
patente es obliga a Estados Unidos a
tener que dar el permiso Expreso sí
permite que lleguen a Ucrania o no
lleguen a